I'll let you do all the
interprofessional
oh really oh I think you're like the
most professional person I've had on so
far really I just pretend fake it till
you make it
that's a great attitude fake it till you
make it until someone calls you it
sounds like you're faking it man hello
ladies and gentlemen wait that's how I
say anymore
I say hello rejects it's Greg here and
this is hey what's up guys I'm Wendy
Wendy from what's the main thing you're
from yeah I mean I know you from
Collider yeah it's mainly Collider
technically that's that is my job but I
also got my own little channel with my
hubby and we're called the movie couple
the movie couple yes it's cheesy but
happy to get married or anything really
handsome too you guys are a very
attractive couple you're very lucky
you're very lucky
yes planning on having children in a
couple years yeah oh wow fast answer
most people kind of hesitant on that
yeah yeah very impressed Wendy there's
this YouTube channel out there call name
aldo jones Aldo Jones does these things
called weird trailers I don't want to
explain anything to you and Natalie
about okay he did one for Batman V
Superman which one got really big and he
did one for uh like Suicide Squad and
Captain America so bored is for like a
lot of big trailers I feel like I should
have known about this now he has one
called for road one okay okay
I'm scared I'm not gonna tell you
anything about it but it is weird and
there might be some callbacks of things
that you are not familiar with okay but
all these are probably laughing at it
alright you ready for this I'm so
nervous I don't know what are you what
am I gonna see what are you gonna show
me that's good scary scary for this I'm
ready
and Aldo Joan specifically requested he
sent me a message really and asked me to
react to this so I got permission by the
way not planned but I'm wearing my array
uh Oh herb and then I just thought a arm
man from hot topic I just picked it up I
gotta live is right oh my god this is
embarrassing but we're gonna watch Oh
ray yeah
how much like you know Star Wars related
hey baby I was seeing a Dan Akroyd from
ghostbusters we looked that's ready to
that's more more well known rate I would
say
the world is coming and um rain across
the gamut Oh Mellie nice like can you be
trusted director shuckles let's just get
the simple shall we
yes really doing this for the rebellion
every day they grow stronger
yes
she fits perfectly
there's 97.6% chance
Oh
are you with me
Oh
nice I love this I want to see more yeah
they're actually uh they're very why is
all Kisan a special guest not me I don't
understand let's get query on this yeah
okay pineapple man whatever all right I
got if the support is hey pal yeah has
this video called when Bruce Wayne
dances and everybody so funny
yeah real emotions are cheerfully taken
that's a great way to put an acronym to
react thank you so much i dollar
donation all right I can be mention you
if I don't even okay so I have to donate
money to you I gotta be a to anybody
okay I guess I guess I'll Tony five it's
five bucks
we're good cost would you look like this
yeah well yeah it's kinda hard to make
commentary on this one well it's
probably the best thing I seen all day
well you're you're constantly working on
the YouTube field but you don't get a
chance to really check out like YouTube
videos at all yeah so this is nice like
I usually have to watch you know other
people's videos making sure our videos
we're looking good going back to our
videos check in comments and then I'll
watch the shows and maybe a little bit
of Jeremy and I'll watch you guys but I
don't get to kind of play on me you do
you don't actually watches new you don't
actually watch it tell me like you guys
know I was just on the Schmo dad we John
and I were just on the Schmo death and
uh I wanted to present rooting for you
guys
were you really yeah I also have never
heard of etc' but you very much TV heck
yeah well you actually know John
actually no John yes
Casey guys I know this John's working at
Horror Nights go find him he looks scary
did punch him no one theme park where
you're allowed to punch people
I believe that's how it goes that's
terrible yeah what is like you punch
them in a make a punch back so it's
complete fairy yeah sure all right when
do you have an idea for Aldo since him
and I talk sometimes okay we're just
gonna submit our photos for you right
now we'll be in our next weird trail
let's do it
all right ready we just need a different
emotion just as you asked try emotions
we have acting experience that's right
sorta all right all right so what's the
what's the first obvious obviously I'm
happy right B yeah sure
you call the next one let's do scared
kind of like um you know that's cute
John give us one where you do any
emotion any emotion for you Aldo
constipate
it could be discussed
joyful
Jose
that's your jello space mm-hmm what does
he have that there you go algo now you
have the next photos to use in your next
weird trailer I'm gonna check out your
channel the pig exactly yeah his
trailers are normally weird like can go
even crazier depending on the kind of
trailer he has you know but it's like
fast pace and whatnot it's gonna he's
gonna like throw a much more craziness
so he tries to blend it seamlessly it's
actually really impressive what its just
gonna say it's completely seamless and
it's you know you you know you're seeing
various you know callbacks and
references but you it's not completely
standing out where it's awkward that's
true wow you're really good at this
you're like way better at commenting on
his video than I that I've ever been I
was a little worried like honey really
may provide commentary on this this is
very you can yeah well you can because
it's a damn good video Aldo hell yeah
and because it's has the same music from
road one this video is not monetized
Thank You Aldo nice thank you no you
can't make money yeah it's all about
making money in YouTube what other
purpose is there ask any channel any
channel boobs YouTube's new boobs oh
that's another reason to go watch your
chick watch me John yet not the young I
don't have that - my bad alright guys
well thanks for tuning in if you're new
to the channel subscribe to day become a
reject wendy is on collider video she
also has her own channel the movie
couple with her awesome husband six pack
abs bulging biceps man titties through
the roof that are just so like you could
bounce like a fingernail on it yeah it's
pretty impressive it's pretty impressive
I haven't met you yet but this is really
just the way yeah we're gonna have to
make it happen yeah okay I don't really
care about Wendy's I saw you in the
video no this is all just a my little
six degrees of separation thing here
going on that's right